it's that time of the year again and
what better way to get into the
christmas and holiday spirit than by
taking a look at some of its weirdest
and most terrifying legends
okay so i can think of about a dozen
better ways but at least i can share
this one with you
in store today we have all sorts of
weird stories from crazy goblins a child
eating giantess her also giant killer
cat and much more
before we delve any deeper a quick word
from today's sponsor scentbird the
fragrance-based subscription service
that is a perfect gift for any occasion
if you give someone a scent bird
subscription as a gift they can pick out
the fragrances they want to try so
instead of paying full price for a
perfume or cologne they've never smelt
before they receive a sample for a
fraction of the price the scentbird
vials are not your average testers which
are gone in two or three sprays they are
eight times larger which is enough for
30 days if a subscription service isn't
for them scentbird also has a host of
gift boxes to choose from with all the
best-selling brands such as dolce
gabbana gucci calvin klein and many more
they have fragrances for both men and
women as well as a selection of unisex
options if you decide to treat someone
or even yourself to a scentbird
subscription then use code mfe30
to get 30 of your first month
subscription which means you only pay
about 11
it's also now available in canada
we start today with our first of three
stories that originate from iceland who
seem to be more than fond of the darker
and mischievous christmas stories
grilla is a giantess or troll who
originally was mentioned in the prose
edda but since has become associated
with christmas
her appearance is fairly repulsive a
giant hag who has a taste for children
in some stories she is a beggar who
roams the streets asking parents to give
her their misbehaving children this can
be avoided by chasing her off or by
simply giving her some food
originally grilla was said to live in a
small cottage but she was chased away by
the town forcing her to retreat to a
secluded cave only to then resurface
during the christmas period
she is able to tell when children have
been misbehaving and so when christmas
comes and she leaves her cave she knows
which children to target
throwing them into her giant bag and
taking them home to make some delicious
timmy stew
she also has 13 children known as the
yule lads and a pet cat known as the
you'll cat
now if you think someone like grilla
would have a regular run-of-the-mill cat
i'm afraid you are deeply mistaken the
yule cat was an enormous feline with
razor whiskers claws that could shred
through anything and just like its owner
a taste for human flesh
it roams the snowy countryside during
the winter looking for children to
devour who had not received any new
clothing during christmas
hence the tradition of families giving
each other new clothing as christmas
presents
as if someone like grilla wasn't enough
children were also told if they didn't
work hard enough throughout the year
they would also have to be worried about
being eaten by the yule cat
as these traditions became more child
friendly the story was slightly altered
those who didn't receive any new
clothing for christmas would instead
have their christmas feast stolen and
eaten by the yule cat
to complete our trio of icelandic
stories we have the thirteen sons of
grilla the yule lads or as i prefer to
call them the christmas mini mad lads
starting from the 12th of december each
night one of them arrives in town where
they remain for 13 days the last
arriving on christmas eve
these menaces are tricksters and their
names reflect how annoying they can be
candle stealer
window peeper sausage stealer pot
scraper and some of my personal
favorites window liquor and doorway
sniffer for the most part they go around
harassing people making a mess and being
as mischievous as possible
it's a tradition for children to leave
their shoes by a windowsill if those
children have been well behaved the yule
lads will leave them a present in their
shoes
those like timmy who have been not so
well behaved are left with a potato in
their shoe
originally the stories of the yule lads
were far more violent and gruesome
similar to stories of their mother but
over time they became more comical and
child friendly it's difficult to
describe how they appear the best i
could come up with is a mix between the
seven dwarfs and santa's elves only way
more chaotic
in italy there are stories of a woman
known as la bafana an old woman who
delivers presents to children similar to
santa claus but instead on the 5th of
january
the name befana is thought to derive
from epiphany with the feast of epiphany
taking place the day after she delivers
her presence her origin goes back to the
birth of jesus buffana was approached by
three wise men asking for directions
as she was known as the best housekeeper
in the village she offered for them to
stay the night having such a pleasant
stay the three wise men then offered
befana the chance to join them on their
journey however she respectfully
declined as she had too much to do
eventually changing her mind she set off
to find the three wise men and visit
baby jesus
she gathered all manner of presence to
take with her however her search was
unsuccessful
guided by the stars she visited the
homes of all the children she came
across giving them presents and hoping
to eventually find the baby jesus
and so it became tradition
the same time every year she set off
visiting the homes of children and
giving them presents however misbehaving
children would receive a lump of coal
just like timmy
bothana is often portrayed riding her
broomstick which throughout the year she
would use to clean her house however
during the christmas period it was her
preferred mode of transportation
similar to santa she entered the homes
through their chimneys and with her she
carried a large hamper packed full of
sweets and all manner of presents
a list of christmas creatures is never
complete without some grubby little
goblins
in greece and the balkans there are
stories of the kalikantseros
or the galaganzaros if you wanted
something closer to the original
these are essentially evil goblins who
live underground for most of the year
that is until the 12 days of christmas
where they surface to cause chaos and
kidnap children who were born on the 12
days of christmas
legend states they live underground
soaring away at the tree of life and its
roots trying to destroy everything
during the 12 days of christmas they
surface and remain above ground for 14
days which gives the tree enough time to
restore itself
in general they are a big nuisance they
want to enter your house cause a mess
and wreak havoc
it's also said that children born on the
12 days of christmas can see and talk to
these creatures with some even fearing
they could become one
to combat this parents would tie a small
string of garlic cloves to their child
as a repellent there are some other
precautions one can take to ensure their
house remains goblin-free burning things
in your fireplace will make your chimney
much harder to enter as the smoke acts
as a repellent
placing a colander outside your door
also works as they will feel compelled
to sit down and count every single hull
however with the number three being a
sacred number they cannot say it out
loud without bursting into flames and so
they will start over and over again
leaving them counting and distracted all
night
now i did ask some family members about
this legend in particular i was told it
was a fairly common tradition to throw a
specific type of sausage as well as a
dessert that is essentially deep fried
dough doubles onto your roof
this is done as somewhat of an offering
or distraction as once they are done
with the food they just go away
so if you ever see someone throwing
sausages onto their roof around
christmas time
i mean they're probably still crazy but
they could have a small goblin issue
and with that we end this holiday
special
hopefully you've enjoyed yourselves
merry christmas and happy holidays
as always
i've been your host mythology and
fiction explained
reminding you to stay away from anyone
called window licker or doorway sniffer
[Music]
you